من الرياض تنضم الينا المتحدثه الاقليميه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه هاله غريط سيده
هلا مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض ما هي الدوافع وراء هذه الزياره
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ايضا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان في هذا التوقيت
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه وانا فرحانه جدا
اكون معكم من الرياض هذا هذه الزياره من
وزير بلينكن تظهر اهميه العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده ومملكه العربيه السعوديه
كما سمعنا العلاقات الثانويه بين البلدين
يعني
تاريخيه استراتيجيه مهمه جدا اكثر من 80
سنه العلاقات عميقه وهذه هذه الزياره مهمه
بالنسبه للعلاقه الثانويه ولكن كذلك
الاقليميه والدوليه
تفضل
العلاقه كما ذكرتي ممتده لثمانيه عقود لكن
مع هذه الاداره الامريكيه كما يرى الكثير
من المراقبين
بانها يعني مختلفه تتصاعد في احيان وتهبط
ربما في احيان الملفات التي تم نقاشها في
هذه ايضا حتى لو في هذا اللقاء وصفها
بانها ملفات كثيره لاحد الصحفيين فما هي
اولويات الخارجيه الامريكيه في هذه
الزياره وفي اللقاء الذي تم ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
هي الاداره العلاقات قويه جدا اكيد هناك
تحديات بين كل الحلفاء وكل شركاء ولان نحن
عندنا علاقه قويه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ممكن نتحدث ونناقشوا على كثير من
الملفات منها
التحديات ولكن هذا لان العلاقه قويه بس
الوزير كما سمعنا كان امس في الجده وكان
عنده لقاء مع واهل عهد محمد بن سلمان
وناقشوا كثير من الملفات منها السودان
ويعني العلاقات الثنائيه
لا اريد ارتبط كثير من الوزير نفسه لان هل
سنسمع غدا من من الوزير نفسه ولكن الان
كذلك هو هو الان في الرياض واصل هذا اليوم
في الرياض واستيقابل مع مع قيادات نساء
سعوديات هذا هذا شيء مهم جدا وسي
[موسيقى]
لهذه الاستراتيجيه
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات